so far we've been focused on the
elasticity of demand for only one good
we've thought about how changes in the
price of that good affect changes in its
quantity now where we're going to
explore is how we can go across goods so
we're going to talk about the cross
elasticity of demand cross elasticity
tissa t of demand and there's multiple
different scenarios we can think about
but it's really thinking about how price
change in one good might affect the
quantity demanded in another good and to
see an example of this think about two
airlines to competing airlines maybe
it's the same exact route going at the
exact same time maybe between New York
and London so airline one right over
here
airline two very competitive price right
over here is $1,000 for a roundtrip
quantity demanded is 200 tickets let's
say in a given week airline - price is
$1,000 for the round-trip and the
quantity demanded is 200 tickets as well
now let's think about what will happen
what will happen if airline one raises
its price raises its price from $1,000
to $1,100 to $1,100 in fact we we could
even do something less dramatic than
that - 1052 1050 so a relatively small
increase in price and remember when we
think about the percentage price
increase we're thinking about
elasticity's in in general we don't just
say okay $50 on top of a thousand
dollars that's a 5% price increase
that's what we would do in kind of
everyday thinking if you said you went
from $1000 to 1050 you would say that's
a 50% I'm sorry that is a $50 increase
on the base of a thousand or that is a
5% increase but when you think about
elasticity's because we want to have the
same percent change between if you go
from 1,000 to 1050 or if you go from
1050 down to a thousand we actually use
the average point as the base so the
percent change in this scenario let me
write it right over here so our percent
our percent change change and I'll write
it in quotes because it's a little bit
different than what you do in
traditional
automatics when you think about percent
changes is you had a 50 change in price
your price went up by 50 and on our base
we will use 1025 which is the average of
a thousand and 1050 and so that gives us
a change of that gives us a change of
fifty divided by 10 25 is equal to let's
say let's say roughly four point nine
percent so this is approximately four
point nine percent will say increase in
price although we're going to put that
increase in quotes because we're using
it on the average and we do that so that
if we said it was ten fifty two thousand
it would still be a four point nine
percent decrease using this same idea
using the midpoint as the base now when
that happens you know everyone today
they use these travel sites where you
can compare prices and people if these
really are the exact same route going
from the exact same airport to the exact
same to the other Airport in London
leaving at the exact same time everyone
is going to gravitate to this one now
because it's only $1000 even just to
save 50 dollars why would they ride on
this airline so this quantity demand is
going to go to zero and this quantity
demanded is going to go to 400 and we're
not going to think about the actual
capacity of the planes and all that
we're going to have a very simple model
here so what was the percent change in
quantity for airline two right over here
well once again our change in quantity
is two hundred not four hundred its we
went from 200 to 400 so we gained two
hundred and our base we want to use the
average of 200 and 400 which is 300 and
so this is approximately this is
approximately 67% so we have all of a
sudden our cross elasticity of demand
for airline twos for airline twos
tickets relative relative to a one's a
one's price and we get the percent
change in a 2's tickets the precisely
the percent change in the quantity
demanded for a to stick 'its which is 67
and over the percent change not in a
two's price change but in a ones price
change that's what we call it cross
elasticity we're going from one good to
another over so so that's roughly well
let's just say for simplicity roughly
five percent roughly five percent and so
you do the math this gets us to so if
you have 67 percent 67 percent divided
by five percent you get to roughly
thirteen point four so this is
approximately thirteen point four so you
have a very high cross elasticity of
demand in fact if you even increase this
maybe by five dollars you might have had
the same effect and so you would have
had a very a very large number here and
that situation right here for this cross
elasticity demand it's because these
things are near perfect substitutes the
way that we set up this problem we said
well people don't care which one they
take they're just going to go for the
cheapest one and so when you have near
substitutes near substitutes or nearly
perfect substitutes nearly perfect
perfect substitutes substitutes for each
other like this example right here the
elast the cross elasticity of demand
approaches approaches infinity it gets
higher and higher and higher in theory
if these are really really really
identical even if you raise this a penny
people say well why would I waste a
penny I would just use airline two and
so this number would be even lower right
over here and so this thing might
approach a fitted infinity and notice
this was a positive this was a positive
when we just did regular price
elasticity of demand the only way that
you would increase quantity for
traditional good the way you would
increase quantity was by lowering price
but here we raise price on a substitute
competitive product and we raised demand
for your product which actually or for
airline twos product which actually made
a lot of sense so it wasn't it wasn't a
negative relationship it's actually a
positive value right over here but you
could have things in other you could
have that negative relationship using
cross elasticity demand this is an
example of a substitute we could think
about the example of a compliment
compliment so what if what if we're
talking about what if we're talking
about ebooks so let's say I have some
type of an e-book and the current
quantity demanded in a given week I
don't know is 1000 and let's say that
the price of an e-reader that you would
need from my eBook the current price for
an e-reader is $100 but let's say that
price of the e-reader
goes down from $100 to I don't know goes
down from $100 to $80 so you had a you
had a $20 decrease in price well what's
going to happen to my eBook just even
holding its price it assuming it's price
does not change well then the quantity
demanded from my eBook will go up so
let's say the quantity demanded for my
eBook goes up by a hundred because more
people are going to be able before this
or they're going to have money left over
when they buy this to buy more ebooks
and so I don't even know what the price
for my eBook is but at a given price
point the quantity demanded will go up
and so this goes to 1100 and so I'll
leave it to you to calculate this
elasticity price elasticity of demand
but you will see that you will actually
get a negative value like we're used to
seeing for regular price elasticity
demand and when you do calculate
remember you would do you want to do
your percent price change percent change
in ebook ebook quantity over percent
change in eReader an e-reader an
e-reader price and the other thing you
have to remember you don't just take
negative 20 over 100 you take negative
20 over the average of these two when
you're thinking of it in the elasticity
context so this right over here actually
maybe we'll just work it through pause
it and try to do it yourself so this
value right over here this one right
over here is negative 20 negative 20
over 90 the average of those two and
this value right over here is going to
be plus 100 plus 100 over the average of
these two so the average of those two is
10:50 and so we get we get so this is
100 divided by 10 50 which gets you to
about 0.95 so about nine and a half
percent change in quantity demanded from
my book and then this this denominator
right here what did I do
the denominator right there is negative
20 negative 20 divided by 90 negative 20
divided by 90 so you get a drop in 12
22% and so if you divide the numerator
by the denominator you get zero point
nine five two divided by negative point
two two two two two I'll just put a
couple two is there and you get a
negative point four three so this is
equal to negative point four three point
zero point four three and this makes
sense if you lower the price of a
eReader this complement product a
product that goes along with my ebook it
increases the demand so you just like
you get with price elasticity of demand
you get a negative value over here
and what about completely two unrelated
products so let's say let's say that I
have basketballs
basketballs and the price of basketballs
goes from let's say they go from $20 to
$30 what's going to happen to my ebook
well my ebooks not going to change its
going to stay at $1,000 so my percent
change in the my percent change in the
quantity demanded of my ebook is going
to be zero in this example so we're
going to have zero and we want to do
this cross elasticity of demand over my
percent change in basketballs which
would be 30 over 25 so whatever whatever
that is what is that that's like 30 over
25 that'd be a or five there would be a
10 over 25 I should say sorry which is a
40 percent increase so that would be 0
over 40 percent which equals 0 so for
unrelated products products where the
price change in one of them does not
affect the quantity demanded in the
other it makes complete sense that you
have a zero cross eli
city of demand if their compliments you
would have a negative cross the
elasticity of demand and if they're
substitutes you would have a positive
one and the closer the substitutes they
are the more positive your cross
elasticity of demand is going to be